so let's think about what we did in that
last video and maybe drew in a little
bit more of a visual way so let's let's
let me let's say this rectangle that I'm
about to draw is the set of all the
things all of all of the things that can
that that I guess can happen the set of
all of the outcomes right and we know
from the get-go and we're still doing
that same example where I have a bag of
coins and one of them only has heads on
it two sides or heads the other ones are
normal so if this is the whole set of
things we know that there's a one-tenth
chance that we pick the coin that only
has head so let me see out of this area
I don't know this is half that's 1/4 1/4
so 1/10 is going to be about that much
roughly so this area right here that
area right there let me color it let me
color it a color so that area right
there that area this is the chances that
we got the two-sided coin two-sided coin
and this whole area this this is all a
normal coin right and then we said oh
you know what what are the chances that
we got fought we get 5 heads in a row
well if we got a normal coin there was a
1 out of 32 chance that we get 5 and in
a row so whatever this area is 1 out of
32 so I'll do it a column you know it's
roughly there I can be a little messy
that this and I'm assuming that this
column right here is 1/32 is 1/32 of
this normal area of this normal area
right so this is a situation of normal
I'll just fry this N and that's upside
down you means and and set theory or
it's a kind of intersection but it means
and I got 5 out of 5 heads 5 out of 5
heads right and if we think about what
is the area of this well it's going to
be the area it's 1/32 of the normal area
right and the normal area is 9 tenths
right so this is equal to
the normal area which is nine tenths and
then 1/32 of that times 1 over 32 right
or you could also another way of viewing
that area you could say that
well that area that's the probability
I'll do the same color that's the
probability of me getting I'll just
write 5 out of 5 5 out of 5 means 5 out
of 5 heads that's the probability of
getting 5 out of 5 heads given that I
got that I picked a normal coin out
right times the probability that I
picked out a normal coin all right and
so this is this is 1 out of 32 and this
is 9 out of 10 and I'm assuming that the
area of this entire magenta rectangle
area that's 1 or 100% or however you
want to view it and so this is 1 out of
32 times 9 out of 10 so this is 9 out of
32 so this whole thing the area of this
entire magenta rectangle is is 1 then
the area of this area this that I just
shaded in this is 9 over three hundred
and twentieth so 9 over 3 20 and another
way of viewing this this is also the
probability this is this area right here
is also the probability that I got 5 out
of 5 and that I picked the normal coin
right so that's also equal to both of
those things are true in this area in
this area if I have a point in that area
it's might be able to abstract for you
if at any point it is true that I got 5
out of 5 and I have picked a normal coin
so that's also going to be equal to and
I'm doing a arbitrary color change here
9 out of 320 so we could say in general
that the probability the probability of
me of me getting 5 out of 5 coins given
that I got a normal coin times the
probability that I got the normal
coin that is going to be equal that I
get that five out of five happens and I
got the normal that equals probability
of five out of five and I got the normal
coin fair enough
so what let's say whether the other side
of this this this kind of yellowish
color here there's a probability I got a
two-sided coin and then given that
what's the probability that you get five
out of five well pretty much this entire
area it's also true that I get five out
of five right so the probability that I
get so the probability that I get five
out of five and two-sided it's equal to
the probability I'm sorry and and
two-sided is equal to the probability of
five out of five given the two-sided
coin times the probability of the
two-sided coin so this is one right if I
got the two-sided coin I'm definitely
gonna get five out of five and that's
why this whole areas is fit is filled in
and then the probability of the
two-sided coin we know already is one
out of ten so this area is one out of
ten one out of ten and so what what is
the total area where I have five out of
five well it's going to be this area
over here which I figured out which was
which was nine three twenty it's nine 3
twentieths of this entire rectangle and
then this whole area is also another
area where I got five out of five
because I've picked the two-sided coin
and that's one-tenth and so by in the
last video we would essentially if we
want to know the chances of getting five
out of five it's this total rectangle
and I say this without showing you
anything so me it'll be read that and I
think you get the point that is the five
out of five so it's going to be this
area plus this area and that is why it
was nine out of 3 twentieths plus one
out of ten and we had the answer last
time fair enough so let me pose a
slightly more difficult
I don't know if I should have just
erased that but I did so let's move
forward what is the probability that I
picked the two-sided coin given that I
got 5 out of 5 heads and remember this
is different than the probability that I
get 5 out of 5 heads given the two-sided
coin what's the difference this says I
pick the two-sided coin now what's the
probability got 5 out of 5 well that's
equal to 1
we're guaranteed to get a million heads
in a row but this says I and I picked I
took I put my hand in the bag I didn't
look at which coin I got I just flipped
it 5 times and I know that I got 5 heads
in a row so now I say well what is the
probability without I guess you know
looking at the coin what is the
probability that this was the two-sided
coin that I picked up well we can go
back to what we said before and let me
just say a little bit abstract from the
last before I clear this we know that
the probability of a given B or right
the probability of well actually let me
let me start on the probability of a and
B happening if you remember that thing
that before I erase it it's a
probability of a given that B happened
times the probability that B happens
right but if both of these things have
to happen then we could say well
definitely B has to happen and then
whatever is the probability of a
happening given that B happened and
these could be exclusive events I mean
this this could be if these are
independent this could be equal to the
probability of a time's the probability
of B but we don't know for sure that
they're exclusive events so you know
probably of a given B could be the
probability of a it might not be
dependent on B at all but we don't know
that but anyway let's ignore that so the
probability of a given B is that but we
also know that the probability of a
given B is equal to I mean you know the
probability sorry we also know the
probability of a and B is also the same
thing as the probability of B and a
happening right the same thing and so
that's the probability of B given that a
happened times the probability that a
happened by the same logic well we see
that this is equal to this so this has
to be equal to that so let's write that
down and we're going to do a lot of
applications I know this is a little
abstract right now but so that tells us
the probability of a given B times the
probability of B is equal to the
probability of B given a time's the
probability of a and then let's just
divide both sides by a and we get this
the probability of B given a is equal to
this probability of a given B times the
probability of B divided by the
probability of a and this is called
Bayes theorem or Bayes law and this is
what we will now use to figure out the
probability that we got the two-sided
coin after seeing that it we rolled or
we flipped we got five heads in a row
see you in the next video